christian quesada ce candidat les 12
coups de midi sur tf1 c'est laid pour
avoir remporté de nombreux cas en 2016
avait été condamné pour détention
d'imagés à caractère pédopornographique
et de corruption mineurs la semaine
dernière il a été remis en liberté deux
ans après son incarcération christian
quesada j'ai finalement sorti de prison
qu'il avait bien été condamné à trois
ans d'emprisonnement par le jeu des
remises de peine christian kestana est
aujourd'hui de nouveau un homme libre
une libération qui a mis en colère de
nombreux internautes pardon
christian quesada et libre c'est quoi ce
pays qui protègent les pédophiles à télé
star jean luc reichmann animateur du jeu
qui a rendu quesada célèbre a expliqué
la justice a parlé et ce n'est plus mon
histoire
il a fallu que je prenne de la distance
ce que j'ai fait depuis longtemps alors
colère des internautes après la
libération de christian quesada est il
sorti trop tôt
ce soir nous vous faisons de nouvelles
révélations sur la sphère quesada et
laurine une de ses anciennes amies sera
là pour témoigner sur le plateau colère
des internautes et vous allez voir des
images exclusives qui ont montré dans un
instant roland perez merci avocat merci
d'être là bon roland et merci à laurine
ancien ami de questions quesada on passe
tout à la dernière prennent alors
laurine vous étiez une amie de christian
quesada oui vous savez quel âge d'origny
acteurs n'ont pas ce que vous faites
encore plus jeune que 21 mai une amie de
christian quesada ce qu'il a il a 56 ans
aujourd'hui c'est une amie avec lui à
combien de temps à 17 ans 17 ans non
mais alors comment quand vous êtes
devenus amis et christian quesada quels
rapports en fait entre nous deux mais en
fait j'aimais beaucoup son émission bien
sûr les douze communes il est excellent
on va pas se mentir et pour ça il était
vraiment que ces langues de cultures
ah oui et c'est ce que j'appréciais
parce que j'aimais beaucoup à apprendre
avec lui j'aurais tellement de choses et
je l'avais contacté
oui je les contacte et sur facebook donc
c'était pour le dire que mais qui était
très fort et que c'est dommage qu'elle
avait perdu mais c'est le jeu normal
comme plein d'aujourd'hui voilà les suis
content bien s'arrêter un jour de toute
manière bien sûr mais si c'est vrai
qu'ils étaient impressionnants dans le
jeu donc forcément vous êtes 10 gige
voilà j'ai envie de me témoigner mon
amitié
oui voilà donc vous aviez 17 ans il vous
a il vous a répondu tout de suite et
marées point lieu quelques mois plus
tard
d'accord il vous a dit il m'avait dit
ben merci beaucoup de tous nos
encouragements et oui comme tu dis c'est
le jeu et
[Musique]
et après c'est tout ce qu'il m'avait dit
pour le moment
april était venu me reparler cette fois
ci sur twitter vous êtes rencontrés
après oui on s'est rencontré un an après
comment c'est lui qui sera proposé de le
rencontrer oui c'est lui qui m'a demandé
s'il voulait se rencontrer en vrai donc
j'avais accepté
elle était venue à nice donc chez moi
donc il avait rencontré ma famille
d'accord ouais d'accord et vous êtes
devenus copains de oui oui oui vous êtes
vu combien de fois on s'est vus 4 x 4
fois avec vous il a jamais eu de
comportement inapproprié
au tout début non d'accord mais c'est au
fil du temps fait qu'on se parle et
qu'après ça voilà ça quand je les
rencontre et enfin quand je suis venu
chez lui dans l'ain ce qui m'avait
invité j'étais tout seul non non il est
venu me chercher à nice mais vous êtes
allé une seule chanson aux parents oui
vous êtes parti de nice donc avec lui
dans l'ain
oui d'accord vous avez vous n'aviez pas
peur de partir seul avec lui comme ça
non non j'ai confiance en lui
au décor est donc vous êtes partent avec
lui dans l'ain oui et qu'est-ce qui se
passe je vous sens ému si vous voulez
regarder on passe peut-être mais ça m'a
joué oui je veux bien
je sais je vous en parlerai quand quand
vous pourrez d'accord il ya aucun
problème laurine alors demain on devra
la face cachée de christian quesada et
dans ce documentaire vous révéler en
exclusivité qui aux gens dont le contenu
de la plainte de clarisse qui a tout
déclenché christian quesada qui se
faisait passer pour une femme pour
récupérer des photos dénudées de jeune
fille qui rêvait de rencontrer des
personnalités de la télévision regarder
procuré des extraits de la plainte de
clarisse
keane ferrand me demandent des photos de
mon sexe et de ma poitrine
elle voulait que ça se fasse le soir
elle me demandait tous les jours je lui
ai envoyé plusieurs photos de mon sexe
et de ma poitrine
je me sentais obligé de lui envoyer ces
photos je me suis toujours exécuté avec
clarisse christian quesada alias justin
ne compte pas en rester là
après avoir échangé avec elle des
dizaines de photos il lui fait une
proposition des plus malsaines
il va ensuite lui proposer des rendez
vous tarifés
c'est sang pour mater 150 pour rouler
des pelles et 200 s'il met la langue
dans l' incroyable a déjà ce premier
extrait et vous allez voir les autres
extraits sont complètement fous guy roux
genton c'est incroyable alors chris
anker sanaa avait un pseudo sur les
réseaux sociaux il se faisait appeler
justin ferrand en fait avec ce pseudo il
contacté des jeunes femmes souvent
mineurs il leur demandait des photos
d'elle dénudée fossard clarisse en
question c'est une jeune femme qui est
autiste donc c'est important de le
savoir aussi christian quesada cibler
des victimes faibles faible
psychologiquement qui était en
admiration devant les personnes qui qui
qui passent à la télévision et donc il
lui promettait toujours de cacher
derrière son pseudo de justine une
rencontre avec une personnalité de la
télévision
cette personnalité c'est christian
quesada et il est allé jusqu'à fixer une
grille de tarifs qu'on a vu à l'instant
qu'ils allaient 250 à 300 euros
et on dit souvent dans cette affaire il
ya pas eu de passage à l'acte certes
mais il a voulu passer à l'acte
puisqu'il a attendu dans un hôtel
plusieurs fois deux matins de suite il
l'a attendu toujours caché sous son
pseudo de justin en lui disant va zy va
voir christian quesada il t'attend à
l'hôtel et il a même disputé après parce
qu'elle n'est pas venue
et c'est justement suite à ça que cette
jeune femme a décidé de porter plainte
laurine je vois non parce que la raison
c'est vrai ce que jeune fille est venue
me parler et en fait elle est venue
jusqu'à l'autel donc pour rencontrer
christian et il lui a fait du chantage
il a dit si tu viens pas avec tu
rencontreras pas si rennes est en vrai
oui donc donc un génocide est incessant
elle est venue donc elle a passé la nuit
à l'hôtel et donc du coup ils ont dû
dormir ensemble elle a eu très peur donc
l appeler sa mère et à sa mère lui a dit
écoutez christian j'espère que tu
consommes ma fille parce que sinon ça va
mal se passer
donc au final après la jeune si elle a
pu aller sur le plateau pour rencontrer
je sais plus qui s'est donc je crois que
c'est mérité
quand on est invité et side jeune fille
qui est assez grand à ses mimes voie
lactée très gentil un mini saint amour
et c'est vrai que c'est encore une autre
jeudi quand ils vous me dites ça ça me
c'est terrible mais c'est incroyable ça
laurine vous donc vous vous voulez
continuer à parler vous me le dites
sinon on continu des images on discute
est ce que ça va mieux déjà ça va mais
je sais que vous êtes 13e but d'être sur
le plateau tout cas merci d'être là
merci à vous tous
et voilà détendez vous si vous voulez
nous racontez vous nous racontez sinon
vous inquiétez pas eu aucun souci
d'accord d'accord voilà aujourd'hui
voilà ce que quand vous voyez question
quesada dehors vous est ce que ça vous
dérange où il est sorti de prison
oui mais quand même où ça me dérange ce
qu'il n'a pas il est pas resté longtemps
et puis il n'a pas fait envoyer des
photos à vous aussi comme il plus haut
d'autres où il a envoyé la photo dont
didier d'accord comme et jusqu'au bout
de compte maintenant que vous êtes allé
chez lui où après après avoir été chez
lui dans l'ain oui c'est ça quand je
rentre et qu'après je voulais plus
jamais le revoir
redon lankais ce qu'il s'est passé ici
en fait je suis resté quatre jours dans
l'ain ce qu'ils voulaient me faire un
peu visités je sais que tous les doutes
mais on était que tous les deux et vous
deviez dans même chose non non non non
je dormais dans une chambre de son fils
d'accord et lui dans les dents dans la
sienne donc ça se passait très bien
d'accord donc il était très gentil
l'un d'eux est le dernier jour quand on
devait quoi de même ramené sur nice le
matin ils étaient venus dans la chambre
et s'allonge à côté de moi nous y mais
qu'est ce que tu fais après ma bile son
doigt sur la bouche
il a essayé de m'embrasser donc moi je
les repousser et je dîne en question
désolé mais beaucoup tu me ramènes choix
de suite et je peux jamais compensé par
le toit et moi donc
donc après il a il a plus rien dit
émond de l'indus qu'à nice aucun mot
après je suis sorti du train et je n'ai
jamais parlé après gille est bloquée de
partout comment il vous a quand même
envoyé des photos
voilà c'était quand oui sur twitter
puisque je n'avais pas bloquer du coup
il m'avait envoyé son zizi
quelques mois plus tard oui il est terré
dans cette histoire c'est la
manipulation de christian quesada
puisqu'il est venu chez vous avant avec
vos parents il s'est bien comporté
je pense qu'à l'époque vous étiez
mineurs encore oui il a attendu que vous
soyez majeure entre temps il est venu
plusieurs fois et là il vous a fait
venir chez lui vous étiez en toute
confiance puisqu'il s'était bien
comportée chez vous et c'est ça qui est
terrible c'est qu'une fois qui s'est
retrouvé seul avec vous il a
radicalement changé de comportement et
je crois même que quand les gens vous
voyez avec lui à hauteville donc dans
son village il vous demandez mais c'est
qui c'est de cette jeune femme soit
amendée qui s'est dit fermement c'est ma
nièce et non pas du tout d'accord pas du
tout en fait ouais vous entendiez bien
avec lui à la bonne heure franchement
oui il était très gentil et très drôle
et a prié ses victimes s'allonge
reserach prix qu'elle m'avait appris
plein plein de choses mais après ça pas
qui il était comme ça
oui nicolas mais vos parents vous ont
essayé comme ça par la fascinante se
sont pas posé de questions ils ont pas
eu peur propre à ce que vous aviez quand
même 17 ans que vous avez commencé à le
fréquenter
c'est vrai que ma mère n'était pas trop
rassuré et comme après j'avais 18 ans
m'a dit que je pouvais partir mais de
faire très attention
et puis si j'avais un problème fallait
que le téléphone est et que je parte au
plus vite et vous leur avez raconté à
vos parents après ce qui s'était passé
oui ma mère est elle au courant oui
après tous mes proches ils sont au
courant mais mon copain tu me regardes
ce soir je pense à lui fait un bisou ils
ont essayé de l'appeler question quesada
pour lui dire qu'est-ce qui se passe non
non non pas du tout dernière question
vous avez eu peur un moment quand
j'étais chez lui mais j'ai regretté en
fait il mais qu'est-ce que je fais là on
fait qu'il fallait que je parte
donc on heureusement que c'était très
court et très je lui dis moi il faut que
je rentre on peut plus se voir toi et
moi et puis je dis qu'on n'avait pas du
tout le même âge et qu'en fait ça va ça
le faisait pas du tout alors lorsque le
domicile de christian quesada et
perquisitionner les enquêteurs
découvrent des milliers d' images
pédopornographiques dans les ordinateurs
de christian quesada regarder les images
insupportables rien vous à découvrir
dans l'un des deux 1077
vidéo vidéos pédopornographiques
trente mille photos pédo pornographie et
la police va aussi découvrir beaucoup
des changes des conversations sur des
sites avec des jeunes filles auxquelles
ils demandent toujours la même chose des
photos nues il envoie lui des photos de
ses parties intimes
christian quesada posséder sur ses
ordinateurs des photos et des vidéos
mettant en scène des viols de mineurs
quand on parle de mineurs dans cette
affaire on parle de mineurs
qui vont de je dirais pas de 0 à 17 ans
mais enfin c'est pas loin quand même
en tout cas vous avez des enfants cinq
ans enfin devrait enfin pas très ado
parle d'enfants son avocat a beau dire
que christian quesada et êtes attiré par
les adolescentes
j'ai vu les photos je peux vous assurer
qu'il n'avait pas que des adolescentes à
10 12 ans n'est pas de les sens pour moi
taillevent les recherches de christian
quesada sur le web dans un instant oui
il ya des gens qui pour minimiser la
peine de quesada 10
il n'est jamais passé à l'acte alors
certes dans le dossier il n'y a pas une
quelque chose qui fait état d'un passage
à l'acte
en revanche on vous dit que c'est un
fantasme de regarder de 2,2 de fantasmer
sur des viols d'enfants
vous regardez quand même des supports et
des vidéos qui ont été détournés sur des
faits graves il ya des enfants qui ont
réellement souffert lors du tournage de
ces vidéos donc senna pour moi
l'argument du passage du nom passage à
la qui n'est pas recevable ce qui avait
vraiment des enfants qui ont souffert et
ses images en plus il est regardé à
plusieurs ils les échanges et ils se les
procurer sur le dark web un réseau un
peu sombre sur internet anonyme
donc on peut pas dire seulement qu'il
n'est pas passée à l'acte et que c'est
pas si grave que ça c'est extrêmement
grave